well I'm going to read to you now a
message that I've gotten from somebody
like while we were talking no from
a couple days ago is this an intimate
photo because it's not a photo it's a
message from a man named Oliver hi I'm
Oliver nice to meet you
some jazz for you this man he's scatting
for you now is that because on your
profile you said something like tv22 or
something yeah but he he he's a it's a
ha ha it's just a variation of the
hahaha I get it I didn't know it was
just
you were doing some sort of you know
well that explains it because I was like
why is this man jazzing at me like why
is he scatting but then I guess tihihi
sounds a little bit like I mean yeah
yeah I don't know I I look too far into
that but maybe he just was like I'm
gonna get her attention do you think I
should respond
sure what do you spawn with oh I don't
know
I just have a whole
[Music]
I did it and James if he doesn't respond
to me you don't that now I speak fluent
scat wait
so uh what you I didn't tell you I just
pranked you what what did I say I want
to suck your dick
[Laughter]
God he's gonna he's gonna be very happy
with that response okay